♪ ♪ ♪
- L'arrivé d'un nouveau-né,
les vacances en famille,
la sortie pour aller cueillir
des pommes...
Les photos d'enfants sont
partout sur les réseaux sociaux.
- Moi, je ne partage pas, mais,
je veux dire, la famille, c'est
sûr que ça partage un peu.
- Bien, quand elle était plus
bébé, je dirais que j'y allais
vraiment une photo à la fois,
mais j'essayais de la montrer
de trois quarts, de profil,
on la voyait pas trop.
- Ça m'est arrivé deux fois de
mettre une photo : à la rentrée
cette année puis à sa fête
l'an passé; il a 6 ans.
- C'est tout?
- Puis je me sens un peu mal
de l'avoir fait, mais
ça me tentait trop!
- Déjà en 2010, un sondage mené
dans 10 pays, dont le Canada,
révélait que 81 % des enfants de
moins de 2 ans avaient au moins
une photo d'eux quelque part
sur Internet.
- Bien, je trouve que le monde,
c'est sûr qu'ils sont un peu
naïfs. Ils vont trop librement
partager des choses des fois.
Mais c'est parce que les gens
ne voient pas le danger.
Et puis le danger n'est pas
nécessairement si imminent que
ça. C'est qu'il peut le devenir.
- Selon des prédictions de
la banque britannique Barclays,
le partage de photos et
d'informations sur des enfants
par leurs propres parents
sera responsable des deux tiers
des vols d'identité de jeunes
adultes d'ici 2030.
Prenez par exemple
une photo d'anniversaire.
Ça dévoile la date de fête,
l'âge de l'enfant, donc sa date
de naissance, qui est une
information souvent demandée
pour confirmer une identité.
Ou encore une photo d'un enfant
avec son chien. Vous trouvez là
le nom du premier animal
de compagnie de l'enfant,
une des questions de sécurité
souvent utilisées pour accéder
à un compte quand vous avez
oublié votre mot de passe.
Même chose pour une photo
de rentrée scolaire où l'école
est géolocalisée. On rend donc
public le nom de la rue de
l'école primaire de l'enfant,
encore là une question
de sécurité fréquente.
- On sait que les parents
ne le font pas dans une mauvaise
intention. Les parents sont
contents, veulent partager
le quotidien, mais ne réalisent
peut-être pas toute
l'information, se disent
"cette publication-là prise
seule, je n'ai pas mis
tant de renseignements".
Mais c'est l'entièreté de
ce qui est mise en ligne qui,
mis ensemble, permet d'établir,
ma foi, un profil assez complet
de l'enfant.
- Mais certains se demandent
si le problème n'est pas plutôt
ailleurs.
- Aujourd'hui, on peut se faire
offrir une carte de crédit
dans un passage quand on va à
l'aéroport ou dans un commerce.
Et puis ils vont te demander une
date de naissance, ton adresse.
Des choses qui sont sensiblement
banales et que plein de gens
ont. Prouver qui on est avec
notre date de naissance,
c'est un peu ridicule.
- Et si on ne devrait trouver
d'autres moyens de prouver
notre identité?
- Bien, supposons qu'on a
une carte d'identité numérique,
quelque chose qui prouve
vraiment qui on est. On doit
l'avoir sur nous et si on veut
demander une nouvelle carte
de crédit ou transférer une
hypothèque ou faire des choses
qui sont en haut d'un certain
seuil, il faut avoir cette
carte-là en notre possession,
et il faut s'en servir
pour prouver qui on est, bien,
ça réglerait pas mal une partie
du problème.
- En attendant, est-ce que
la solution, c'est d'arrêter
de publier toute photo d'enfant?
Le Commissariat à la protection
de la vie privée du Canada
recommande plutôt aux parents
de respecter les renseignements
personnels de leurs enfants
comme ils respectent
ceux de leurs amis.
- Je dirais, c'est plus
d'être conscient qu'il existe
des risques et peut-être que
ce n'est pas tout qui est bon